so I just told you one story about
someone who did the right thing in the
entire putting kids in internment camp
situation which was child detention
center worker antar Davidson quit his
job when he was told he has to enforce a
rule that prevents detained migrant
siblings from hugging each other I now
have a story about someone doing the
opposite of good in this entire Fiasco
actually doing something completely
horrifying
ProPublica got their hands on a secret
audio recording of a Border Patrol agent
joking around as kids from Central
America were desperately crying when
they were separated from their parents
last week there's the statistics which
we hear about here's the number of
people that are being detained the
number of kids being separated from
their parents and then there's the
reality and the reality I'm gonna play
for you here is absolutely horrifying
and you're gonna hear Spanish being
spoken for the people that are watching
either on YouTube or on free speech TV
or on our television affiliates there
will be translation on screen but to
preview what you're going to hear the
long and short of what's being discussed
in Spanish here is that there are kids
saying things like I don't want him to
deport my dad where my parents things
along those lines this sort of sets the
stage for us
a fourth
[Music]
[Music]
that goes on like this
you don't really even need to speak
Spanish to understand the gist of what's
going on here and then we get to the
really funny jokes from a Border Patrol
agent again in Spanish first saying we
have an orchestra here meaning the
crying of countless children separated
from their parents followed a little
more difficult to hear by all we need is
a conductor again translation on screen
for people who are watching locate that
[Music]
my correction here he actually said
we're missing a maestro not a conductor
but I think you sort of understand the
general point of what he was saying
empathetic right I mean that this isn't
about this one guy to be super clear
this guy actually he sounds like a
native Spanish speaker this this might
be a Hispanic guy who actually does
empathize with what's going on but is
completely desensitized because the
system is really what the problem is
he's been conditioned to find this to
just be another day on the job and I've
got to tell you if the line doesn't get
drawn here where does it get drawn and
I'm not asking rhetorically I'm actually
asking if we don't draw the line here
and now what is going to stop it from
getting much much worse and we do have
people who are increasingly furious
about what's happening in our country
but we also have committed Trumpets who
in their sort of cognitive dissonance
and collective delusion are
rationalizing each of these increasingly
heinous policy acts of the
administration with few exceptions I'll
tell you about a republican exception
after the break and they're going to
support these increasingly extreme
actions so if the idea pat is that we're
going to say listen this is
soul-crushing audio everybody's going to
realize it and even the committed
trumpet will stand up and say this is as
far as we go with this stuff I don't
think it's going to happen we've seen no
evidence that that's going to happen
yeah it probably won't unfortunately I
also wonder whether it's the job that
makes monsters out of these people or if
these people are attracted to these jobs
because they can they can fulfilled how
what they want to do which is to be
monsters themselves I think it's 50/50 I
think the idea is that of the way this
works is individuals who are drawn to
the sort of authoritarian position that
you have as something like a Border
Patrol agent are drawn to that sometimes
they see you have a lot of veterans for
example in Border Patrol sometimes they
see the similar type of hierarchy that
exists in the military as appealing and
then once they're in they get further
sort of desensitize
is to some of the horrible realities of
what's going on I don't think it's one
or the other I think it's probably a
combination of the two and you know
whether you want to call it do do they
lack a conscience do they lack a moral
compass or whatever I think it's far
more complicated than that I think
that's very easy to just say these
people have no conscience I think that
the horrors of what has been established
as almost a mechanism of government is
what normalizes it in this way and it
goes beyond good and bad people yeah I
guess on the bright side there are
people who will take a stand right like
antar Davidson you hold that yes to
separate kids who are hugging and he
decided to quit but you're right in the
sense that someone else is just going to
replace them that's the problem unless
you deal with the underlying policy if
some people say I'm not going to stand
for this and leave they will very
quickly be replaced and you need a much
more sort of systemic up ending of what
it is that we're seeing here after the
break I'll tell you about a Republican
who's actually doing the right thing
kind of now after doing the wrong thing
for many many months I'm on Twitter at D
Pakman the show is on twitter at david
pakman show and we'll be right back